hey 42 here thought to have been made in
and rediscovered by a belgian map
collective the ostrich egg globe
is notable for several reasons the first
and most obvious is that the globe
itself is quite literally
made out of uniquely carved lower halves
of two ostrich eggshells
not only an extremely unusual material
but one that's done well to survive
undamaged
for half a millennium the globe is
thought to be one of the very oldest
in existence and the oldest who featured
the americas
which were discovered a few years
earlier by italian explorer christopher
columbus
in 1492. the globe also includes the
first known usage of the phrase
hexant draconess that's here
are dragons if you don't happen to be
too hot on latin
we usually associate this phrase with
dangerous or uncharted lands on old maps
but its location on the ostrich globe
suggests
another possible explanation just off
the east coast of asia
high schoolness may originally have been
a reference to the island
of komodo home to the world's largest
living lizard the komodo dragon
these monstrous reptiles may not breathe
fire but they can be up to three meters
long
weigh almost as much as an adult male
and are capable of taking down prey as
large as water buffalo
due to some similarities with sketches
made by leonardo da vinci there's some
speculation that the mysterious
ostrich globe was made by the great
italian polymath himself
but that is yet to be proven and since
the globe's owner
appears to be the man behind the
research we can probably take it with a
pinch of salt
whatever its origin take one cursory
look at the ostrich egg globe
and you'll see that the world it depicts
bears only a passing resemblance to one
you've probably zoomed around on google
maps
at one time or another most of the
important bits are included but
the exact shape and position of pretty
much everywhere is
to put it mildly a bit try drawing
a map of the world from memory with your
eyes closed and you'll probably end up
closer to the real thing
than leonardo did on this occasion but
we can hardly blame him given the time
period
most of us use maps on an almost daily
basis we take it for granted that we can
explore our local area or even the
entire world in my new detail
just by taking out our phones and making
a few quick taps
that's probably why it's easy to forget
that highly accurate maps
are actually an extremely recent
invention
before modern mapping techniques came
along our knowledge of exactly
what went where on our very own planet
was at times
almost comically bad to illustrate this
point
i encourage you to grab the nearest
atlas
and try to find the mountains of kong
actually don't bother you'd have about
as much luck scoping around for mordor
that is unless your map happens to be a
little out of date
because whilst the mountains of kung
certainly don't exist
they did appear on the latest and
greatest maps mankind had to offer
as recently as 1892 and we aren't
talking some pokey hills
in and out of the way corner of the
globe here the mountains of kong were
said to form
a majestic range that spanned half of
africa
from guinea to the mountains of moon
which also don't exist just in case you
were wondering
the mountains of kong first showed up on
the maps that were created after the
african expeditions of famous scottish
explorer
mungo park quite how old mungo managed
to explore his way through a mountain
range
that wasn't there isn't known but since
few westerners ventured into that part
of the world at the time
nobody in europe was able to refute the
existence of the mountains
for almost 100 years not knowing any
better cartographers continue to
perpetuate the original error
over and over and over again today
our maps are of course far more accurate
but even now
we can't claim total cartographic
mastery
over every corner of the globe parts of
the amazon rainforest like the
austria-sized vale du jafari
for example which is home to some 6 000
uncontacted or sometimes just a little
bit contacted
indigenous people remains largely
unmapped
to this day then there's gang carpentium
very likely the world's tallest
unclimbed mountain
which is located in bhutan along the
border with tibet
somewhere until very recently world maps
couldn't quite agree on exactly where
that
somewhere was with different maps
showing the mountain in
very different places and listing it at
markedly
different heights there was so much
general confusion around just
where this 7000 meter mountain actually
was
that when bhutan first opened up its
ranges to mountaineers in 1983
the first expedition to attempt to reach
the summit
was unsuccessful not because of the
challenge of the climb or the brutal
conditions
but because the mountaineers couldn't
actually find the mountain in the first
place and it isn't just remote areas
that give modern day cartographers
trouble
the sheer rate of change they have to
deal with means maps become out of date
almost as soon as they're printed
coastlines around the world
shift due to erosion and areas of
intense volcanic activity
can alter the local landscape overnight
we humans
love to mess things up too our roads
cities and agricultural lands change
dramatically from year to year
and we can't get enough of tearing down
forests damming rivers and causing
general mayhem
wherever we go all this without even
considering the truly hard to map places
on earth like
the ocean floor of which only about 19
is currently mapped to any kind of
reasonable resolution
in short the world is very big
very full and it has a habit of changing
in subtle ways
the moment we turn our backs all of
which makes the production
of highly accurate maps difficult and
keeping track of
every tiny detail on those maps almost
impossible
which probably explains how
manhattan-sized
sandy island off the coast of french
territory new caledonia
in the south pacific could be found on
google earth
as recently as 2013. it
no doubt came as something of a surprise
to the team of australian scientists who
paid sandy island a visit in 2012 then
that
it wasn't actually there despite having
appeared on our best maps and
nautical charts for over 100 years
sandy island doesn't exist and very
likely
never did but every once in a while
something erroneous appears on a map not
due to the overactive imagination of
some travel weary explorer or even
because of basic human error
sometimes cartographers get things wrong
quite deliberately take a glory
in delaware county new york as a prime
example
which appeared on maps produced by
one-time top u.s road map publisher
general drafting between 1930 and 1998.
anyone who came across a glory whilst
pursuing the map would see
nothing untoward just a small
insignificant hamlet in upstate new york
but try and actually go there and you
would soon have a problem
because much like sandy island a glory
doesn't exist the name of this fictional
town is in fact an anagram of the
initials of general drafting's founders
otto g lindbergh and ernest alpers
they made it up and placed it on their
map intentionally
but why would a successful map maker put
their good name and reputation
on the line by deliberately sabotaging
their
own product the answer is actually
rather ingenious
as we've already seen cartography is a
challenging business
and even modern technology sometimes
struggles to get things right
back in 1930 making maps was a
time-consuming
painstaking process that involved a
great deal of money
manpower and expertise but whilst good
maps are extremely difficult to make
they're absolutely trivial to copy
get your hands on any well-regarded map
and you could print your own version of
it without too much trouble
and since you wouldn't have to worry
about any of that expensive and
difficult
mapping nonsense you could probably
undercut the original map maker's prices
whilst you were at
it as you've probably guessed already
that's where our glowy new york comes in
it's a copyright trap also known as a
paper town
phantom settlement or sometimes believe
it or not
a mount weasel copyright traps are used
by map makers as a nifty way of catching
plagiarists the idea is simple if
a glory new york ever appeared on a
rival map
otto and ernest of general drafting
would have known immediately that their
intellectual property had been infringed
after all how could anyone else have
possibly plotted a town
that doesn't exist it just so happens
that this particular copyright trap
actually worked or at least it kind of
did because a glory did indeed appear on
a map
produced by one of general drafting's
rivals rand mcnally
some years after the trap was set up the
general drafting
lawyered up and took rand mcnally to
court but whilst it sounds like this was
an open and shut case
there was a catch in the meantime a
general store had been
built on the empty intersection where a
glory was supposed to be located
having spotted the name a glory on his
own
map the owner of the store quite
reasonably decided to call his new place
of business
the glory general store exactly where he
thought the rest of the town was
supposed to be hiding
is unclear but what was crystal clear to
rand mcnelly's lawyers was that a glory
did indeed exist and therefore no
copyright infringement could be proven
unsurprisingly considering nobody else
lived there
the glowy general store went out of
business soon after these events took
place
it turns out copyright traps like a
glory appear on maps all over the world
looking across the pond one of the uk's
most famous maps the london a to z
is known to be riddled with so-called
trap streets
much like paper towns these fictional
streets
are placed in out of the way places
ready to fool
unsuspecting plagiarists and the
occasional lost
chinese tourist according to a 2005
statement from a spokesperson working
for the company who publishes the ataz
the famous guide to london's incredibly
confusing roads and alleyways
contains as many as 100 trap streets
dotted here and there to catch out the
unwary and presumably to confuse the
out of london taxi drivers
completing
the knowledge a test all black cab
drivers must take
which requires them to memorize every
single street
in the english capital one of my
absolute favorite fictional towns
is the city of bielefeld in germany
most copyright traps are hidden in out
of the way places so as to be
effective at weeding out the cheats
whilst being extremely unlikely to trip
people up who are
actually trying to use the map in
question to navigate not so
bielefeld which is purported to be a
prosperous industrial city
of some 300 000 inhabitants located
between munster
and hanover what makes bielefeld even
more unusual as a phantom settlement
however
is the fact that it very much does exist
its non-existence is actually a kind of
light-hearted conspiracy theory based on
three
key questions do you know anyone from
bielefeld
have you ever been to be lefeld do you
know anyone who has ever been to be
lefeld
answering no to each of these questions
as most people naturally do
is used as proof that the individual is
complicit in the conspiracy
which has been going strong for some 25
years
the intention of the blfl conspiracy is
actually to satirize conspiracy
theorists
who quickly believe something to be true
i.e bilafeld
not existing when it quite clearly does
in 2019 the bielefeld council
offered a 1 million euro prize to any
person who could provide
incontrovertible evidence of the city's
non-existence
they received thousands of responses
attempting to do exactly that
through creative use of mathematics
physics
and logic germany's federal office for
geography and surveying even had a crack
at winning the prize
by publishing a brand new map of germany
with bielefeld omitted as it turns out
copyright traps exist
outside of the world of cartography too
remember how i said
that phantom towns are sometimes known
as mount weasels
the name thankfully has nothing to do
with the abuse of small mammals
but is in fact inspired by the 1975
edition
of new colombia encyclopedia which
listed an entry for one
lillian virginia mount weasel now
cartographers are a fairly serious bunch
and they tend to keep things pretty
simple when trying to catch copyright
cheats a tiny fictional street here
and out of the way hamlet's there that
sort of thing
not so the encyclopedia makers
those guys like to go big lillian
virginia mount weasel
was according to the new columbia
encyclopedia
a fountain designer turned photographer
who died in an explosion whilst working
for
combustibles magazine her most famous
work is said to have been
a book called flags up a collection of
photographs of rural american mailboxes
and if you're stupid enough to fall for
that one not only do you very much
deserve to be sued
but you probably shouldn't be making
encyclopedias in the first place
mega author of the false in our stars
fame john green
referenced this most absurd of copyright
chaps in his 2008 novel
paper towns which just as happens to
feature one
a glowy new york prominently in its plot
one of the book's main characters margot
ruff spielgmann
owns a cat called mirna mount weasel a
knot to the late great fountain designer
photographer who is sadly no longer with
us
due to having exploded the new oxford
american dictionary is known to have a
punch on for a spot of mount weasling
too ever heard of the word equivalence
allow me to enlighten you according to
the 2001 edition of the dictionary
equivalence is defined as the willful
avoidance of one's responsibilities
and it is of course utterly made up
god helped a dictionary maker whose
shocking equivalence
saw him copy the word for use in his own
dictionary
of course we youtubers have to watch out
for intellectual property thieves too
which is why i've secreted my very own
round weasel right here in this video
a deliberate mistake that if it ever
appears in someone else's video
i can see the living out of them
happy hunting
and thanks for watching you can now
pre-order my brand new book stick a flag
in it
on amazon link in the description thank
you